bonjour à tous
bonjour madame calaya
nous entendez-vous
on a un retour
parfait
mais monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la commission
des lois chère François Noël mes chers
collègues nous recevons aujourd'hui en
visioconférence madame Aya calmaya
directrice exécutive intérimaire de
l'agence Frontex alors que la Commission
européenne réfléchit à une révision du
règlement 2019 1896 qui encadrent son
action comme vous le savez avec mon
collègue François Noël buffet président
de la commission des lois nous avons été
chargés d'examiner la situation actuelle
de l'agence Madame la Directrice
permettez-moi avant toute chose de
saluer le professionnalisme des
personnels de Frontex dont la mission
est essentielle à la pérennité de notre
espace Schengen
je vous remercie sincèrement pour votre
disponibilité car votre temps est
précieux le poste de directeur exécutif
de Frontex étant très certainement l'un
des plus exigeants de l'Union européenne
et votre nomination est intervenue dans
un contexte troublé en effet Frontex
connaît depuis plusieurs mois à la fois
une crise de croissance et une crise de
confiance la crise de croissance c'est
une agence qui faute de temps pour
recruter l'expertise nécessaire assume
avec difficulté son mandat élargi fin
2019 en particulier dans l'analyse des
risques ou la communication sur ces
opérations
la crise de confiance c'est l'agence
opérationnelle la plus puissante de
l'Union européenne qui est depuis 2020
sous pression en raison d'attaques
continues contre ces actions son
ancienne direction incarnée par Fabrice
l'égérie entre 2015 et avril dernier a
en effet été accusé de complicité de
violation des droits fondamentaux de
migrants traversant la mer Égée ainsi
que de plusieurs irrégularités et
manquements elles ont déclenché une
série inédite d'investigation de
l'Office européen de luth antifraud
l'OLAF du Parlement européen de la Cour
des comptes européennes ou encore du
Médiateur européen une part des
irrégularités manquements allégée a été
confirmé par l'enquête de l'OLAF mais je
dois vous le dire cette enquête qui a
fuité dans la lampe dans la presse et
loin d'être toujours convaincante en
particulier lorsqu'elle accuse Frontex
de violation qui relevait en réalité de
la responsabilité des États membres il
faut le déplorer tout comme il faut
déplorer les divergences existant
aujourd'hui sur les la majorité de
Frontex au sein des institutions
européennes et les conflits de personnes
qui ont fortement contribué à la
situation actuelle ce constat n'est pas
satisfaisant c'est pourquoi je veux
saluer vos efforts pour mettre en œuvre
efficacement les dispositifs de
règlement de 2019 à l'exemple du
meilleur accès au mécanisme de
traitement des plaintes en cas de
violation des droits fondamentaux mais
attention sur ce point ne pas créer une
usine à gaz administrative qui
empêcherait toute prise de décision au
sein de l'agence en raison d'une
atmosphère de défiance et de délation
généralisée en effet il est urgent que
l'agence Frontex puisse de nouveau
obtenir des résultats sur le terrain car
entre janvier et septembre 2022 l'agence
a enregistré une augmentation de 70% en
un an des franchissements irréguliers
aux frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne c'est pourquoi madame la
Directrice pouvez-vous nous expliquer
quelles ont été vos priorités pour le
bon fonctionnement de Frontex depuis
votre nomination
ne pensez-vous pas qu'un pilotage
politique renforcé de l'agence serait
souhaitable enfin pouvez-vous nous
expliquer comment Frontex travail à
améliorer son action en matière de
retour et je passe la parole à François
Noël buffet
merci merci beaucoup bonjour madame je
ne serai pas long en réalité parce que
le président râpin a quasiment tout dit
peut-être simplement quelques mots pour
rappeler
d'abord vous remercier ce matin
d'accepter cette audition mais aussi
pour rappeler que le fonctionnement et
l'efficacité de Frontex est absolument
indispensable indispensable évidemment à
l'échelle européenne cela va sans dire
mais indispensable aussi pour la France
puisque nous avons de plus en plus
recours d'ailleurs
j'ose employé le mot qui est peut-être
maladroit au service de Frontex
notamment dans les mesures de
reconduites et donc pour nous ce n'est
pas un petit sujet
ce n'est d'autant pas un petit sujet que
nous avons depuis plusieurs années à la
commission des lois comme la commission
aux Affaires européennes toujours suivi
de très près l'évolution de cette
institution et singulièrement depuis la
crise migratoire de 2015 ou à partir de
là de grands enjeux évidemment un enjeu
de croissance extrêmement forte dans un
délai extrêmement court donc une
nécessité de structurer
frontext Frontex très très vite
première chose et puis un enjeu cette
fois-ci opérationnel migratoire de mise
en oeuvre d'une politique migratoire
liée à ces événements et donc ça fait
beaucoup de choses en même temps mais
on a aussi vécu comme beaucoup ici
la situation il y a quelques mois qu'il
faut faut-il la qualifier de crise
probablement avec des la mise en cause à
la fois fondamentale et à la fois de
personnes
nous appartient pas de de juger ce n'est
pas notre en revanche nous avons besoin
de comprendre nous avons besoin de
comprendre nous avons besoin qu'on nous
explique parce que nous considérons que
l'agence est pour nous français bien sûr
mais européen surtout un outil
extrêmement utile voilà je voulais m'en
tenir juste à cela peut-être il y aura
plusieurs questions des uns et des
autres ici présents ma manière actrice
mais c'est vrai que ces informations de
l'OLAF qui filtrent dans la presse plus
ou moins organisée par organisé en tous
les cas
qui crée le trouble disons les choses
telles qu'elles sont on a aussi besoin
nous de clarté pour savoir comment on
doit continuer de travailler et comment
on organise les choses voilà j'ai été
beaucoup trop long tous les cas merci de
de votre intervention
c'est à vous madame
merci beaucoup alors pour commencer
j'aimerais vous remercier sincèrement de
m'avoir invité ce matin pour répondre à
vos questions pour parler un petit peu
de vos préoccupations en tant que membre
de la communauté de l'Union européenne
et c'est un privilège pour moi c'est
comme ça que je conçois les choses c'est
un privilège que de pouvoir avoir cet
échange de vue avec vous et je salue
cette opportunité qui m'est donnée
d'entendre qu'elles sont vos
préoccupations et je vais faire de mon
mieux véritablement pour répondre à
toutes vos questions
j'ai pris note
de la liste de questions que vous m'avez
fait parvenir et avec mes collègues nous
allons vous fournir des réponses par
écrit il y aura également des réponses
aux questions
que vous pourrez avoir par la suite
aujourd'hui si nous manquons de temps ou
si il y a un manque de connaissance
comme vous l'avez dit à juste titre
Frontex et l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne et actuellement
confronté à cette situation très
difficile à l'échelle mondiale il y a
l'instrumentalisation de la migration
l'instrumentalisation des gens ce n'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau c'est
quelque chose qui a déjà eu lieu des
époques très anciennes on le voit dans
les livres d'histoire mais on constate
que nos voisins pour atteindre des
objectifs politiques sont prêts à faire
appel à des boucliers humains et ça
c'est vraiment très dérangeant il y a
autre chose également et je crois que
très peu de personnes pensaient que
c'était possible c'est la guerre en
Europe et la guerre a démarré le 24
février dernier nous nous sommes
réveillés avec des nouvelles terribles à
savoir que la Russie avait envahi
l'Ukraine et pas uniquement à un seul
endroit
il y a également comme vous l'avez dit
une pression migratoire croissante
et cela concerne l'ensemble des
frontières de l'Union européenne vous
avez dit qu'il y avait
73% d'augmentation du nombre de
franchissement illégaux de la frontière
dans l'Union européenne j'aimerais vous
donner un aperçu de principaux types de
pression alors 130
000 franchissements illégaux pour le
corridor des Balkans occidentaux et cela
signifie qu'il faut impérativement
s'attaquer à cette question de la
gestion des frontières de façon bien
plus large pas uniquement les frontières
de l'Union européenne il faut aller
au-delà
j'aimerais également attirer votre
attention sur l'augmentation de la
violence
aux frontières cela a commencé par les
tirs en Biélorussie
également l'augmentation à la frontière
turque il y a eu également des violences
signalées de plus en plus à la frontière
hongroise serbe ou de plus en plus on
constate une pression migratoire de plus
en plus forte depuis le mois d'août nous
avons vu environ 70 000 franchissements
illégaux de frontières par cette par ce
tronçon de frontières précisément plus
de 150 km de long et c'est très dur à
gérer et enfin j'aimerais également vous
parler des
tirs terribles qui ont eu lieu ce lundi
à la frontière entre la Turquie et la
Bulgarie un garde frontière bulgare a
perdu la vie il a été visé dans la tête
pendant une patrouille et il y a eu
également une deuxième personne qui a
été gravement blessée donc voilà la
situation laquelle nous sommes
confrontés aux frontières de l'Union
européenne et également
c'est ce à quoi mes collègues sont
confrontés lorsqu'ils font leur travail
donc j'aimerais vous remercier vraiment
chaleureusement de bien reconnaître
quels sont les efforts réalisés par le
personnel de Frontex c'est un personnel
qui travaille et qui continue à
travailler malgré les défis il y a des
patrouilles à la frontière bulgare
malgré les tirs il y a eu également des
changements au sein de l'organisation
malgré
les difficultés internes et externes
alors comme vous l'avez également
signalé à juste titre la croissance de
l'agence a été extrêmement rapide et
j'aimerais
très rapidement vous donner un bref
aperçu de la façon dont les choses sont
déroulées sont de l'agence en 2016 donc
la réglementation a été adoptée mais
elle n'a pas été mise en oeuvre
totalement lorsque le règlement 2019 a
été adopté et le règlement de 2019 était
visionnaire et là véritablement apporter
le plus grand changement imaginable pour
ce qui est des gestion des frontières ça
a été adopté par législateur des États
membres de façon visionnaire en donnant
la possibilité à l'Union européenne
d'appuyer les États membres à savoir
l'objectif principal de Frontex
c'est incroyablement important néanmoins
nous savons également que la politique
la part dans la pression politique et
les délais étaient extrêmement serrés et
comme vous l'avez dit à nouveau
et vous avez tout à fait raison cette
croissance a également entraîné des
difficultés à savoir qu'il était
difficile d'opérer cette croissance de
la bonne façon le règlement a été adopté
en décembre 2019 et l'attente était que
le corps permanent donc le personnel de
l'agence serait déployée en janvier un
an plus tard et vous savez quoi nous
l'avons fait nous l'avons fait nous
avons recruté des gens nous les avons
formés nous les avons équipés
d'uniformes et des équipements
nécessaires donc toutes ces personnes
qui ont été déployées le 2 janvier 2020
non est-ce qu'on a tout fait
correctement non bien sûr que non nous
le savions dès le départ c'était
également un des messages de l'agence à
savoir qu'il était impossible en un an
de tout faire correctement pour
différentes raisons du fait de la
pression du temps du fait des politiques
d'achat des politiques de recrutement
des procédures de recrutement également
du fait de l'absence de règles
applicable il n'y avait pas de règle
quant à la façon de recruter ces agents
en uniformes qui ont des pouvoirs
exécutifs qui portent une arme au sein
de l'Union européenne nous avons dû
inventer les règles les modifier au fur
et à mesure que nous avantions nous
étions en
fait nous vivions dans la maison que
nous étions en train de construire et
vraiment nous vous sommes très
reconnaissants d'avoir aussi clairement
marqué le fait que vous étiez conscient
de ce fait et vous avez fourni un
soutien fort et je vous en suis
particulièrement reconnaissante
je le signalerai au personnel de
l'agence je leur en ferai pas parce que
c'est important pour nous de le savoir
c'est important pour mes collègues de
savoir qui ne sont pas seuls et isolés
face au reste du monde maintenant
parlons un petit peu du temps et de la
pression de ton est-ce que les délais
étaient trop serrés je dois dire que
lorsque l'on pense à la guerre qui s'est
déclaré cette année et bien sans cette
pression nous n'aurions pas été en
mesure de déployer des ressources
supplémentaires à la frontière
ukrainienne en quelques jours quelques
semaines à peine comme l'a fait l'agence
donc c'était la bonne décision c'était
une décision opportune c'était
visionnaire et il y a eu toutes sortes
de difficultés mais c'était la bonne
décision
compte tenu de la pression migratoire
la petite étude à avoir des personnels
détachés sur le long terme de la part
des États membres à savoir que les États
membres y compris la France envoient du
personnel à l'agence au corps permanente
de l'agence pendant quelques années et
le personnel donc de l'agence plus ce
personnel détaché nous permet de
redéployer des personnes en quelques
jours à peine alors que par le passé
pour déployer des gens
il nous fallait au moins deux semaines
si vous regardez les délais qui figurent
dans le règlement ces délais sont très
très longs par rapport à ce que nous
avons été en mesure de faire grâce au
corps permanent
dans le même temps
à nouveau vous l'avez dit à juste titre
vous avez signalé le fait que l'agence
travaillait dans un environnement
externe complexe mais également un
environnement interne complexe
suite à la démission de l'ancien
directeur exécutif au mois de mai
on m'a confié
la mission de
d'occuper ce poste par intérêt sous la
supervision du conseil d'administration
et dès le départ côté agence nous avons
eu une approche équipe de direction pour
gérer l'agence pendant cette période de
transition à savoir une approche en
équipe
qui inclut également les directeurs
exécutifs adjoints qui étaient en place
cela
a également
signifier que nous avons fait appel aux
personnel de direction et le personnel
parce que souvent ils ont une meilleure
connaissance que nous de certains
dossiers et cela nous permet de mieux
fonctionner c'est plus opérationnel
à partir du 1er juillet j'ai donc été
nommé directrice exécutive par intérim
avec un pouvoir d'additionnel plein
à l'exception de principaux changements
organisationnel parce que on m'a demandé
d'attendre que le nouveau directeur
exécutif soit nommé ce qui me paraît
tout à fait
juste notre travail
et
étroitement
structurés avec le conseil
d'administration de l'Agence tous les
jours ou toutes les semaines nous sommes
en contact avec le président du conseil
d'administration et nous faisons
également en rapport de nos activités
pendant les réunions régulières pendant
les réunions extraordinaires du conseil
d'administration qui ont été mises en
place afin d'appuyer l'agence pendant la
phase de transition nous avons une
communication excellente avec la
Commission et nous avons également
augmenter nos activités de liaison avec
les parties prenantes j'aimerais
maintenant parler des priorités de
l'agence pendant cette période
intérimaire
il est essentiel
au vu du contexte géopolitique et du
contexte à nos frontières européennes
ensuite la stabilisation de l'agence
pour regagner la confiance des parties
prenantes
confiance en notre agence
et
l'agence est capable de
d'accomplir ses tâches conformément à la
réglementation en vigueur
qu'il s'agisse du droit
européen du droit international en
matière de contrôle des frontières
et enfin c'est très important
améliorer l'environnement de travail
rassurer le personnel le rappeler qu'ils
ne sont pas seuls et je tiens
réitérer mes remerciements à votre égard
et au Parlement européen au Parlement
nationaux également
qui ont fait part de leur soutien
vis-à-vis de l'agence à l'heure actuelle
nous avons besoin d'une agence forte une
agence qui n'est pas seule
et l'agence a besoin d'un soutien fort
de la part des États membres et encore
une fois je le répète merci de votre
soutien l'agence
qui est de des opérations nous déployons
2354 membres du contingent permanent
nous avons
déployés 18 opérations opérations
conjointes au sein de lieu et orue nous
avons les accords de statut dans la
région des Balkans mais de façon
générale nous couvrons plus de 200
localisations cette année nous avons
augmenté
le nombre de retours de façon
significative
c'est un chiffre record
21000 retours de membres du personnel
de retour de migrants
12659 retour forcés et plus de 7000
retours volontaires
cela peut être comparé aux chiffres de
l'année dernière plus de 14000 retours
donc la hausse est de plus de 30%
et la hausse est à comparer avec les
chiffres de l'intégralité de l'année
2021 rappelle l'année 2022 n'est pas
encore terminée pour ce qui est de la
stabilisation de l'agence et de la
conformité
nous sommes parvenus à mettre en œuvre
ce que j'estime comme étant de nombreux
changements
depuis le départ
sur la base des rapports d'audit et la
recommandation
pour ce qui est du groupe de contrôle
parlementaire
les recommandations du Conseil de
Direction le groupe de travail un groupe
de travail a été mis en œuvre pour se
pencher sur la question des refoulements
nous sommes également intéressés aux
conclusions de divers rapports et
les premiers changements dont je
souhaite vous faire part sont dans le
domaine des droits fondamentaux et du
cadre des droits fondamentaux
l'officier responsable de droit
fondamentaux fait désormais partie
de la structure décisionnaire de
l'agence
cet officier des droits fondamentaux et
son équipe ont un accès complet aux
informations disponibles pour accomplir
leurs tâches
le 16 octobre nous avons finalisé le
recrutement de 46 vérificateurs
qui sont aidés par d'autres membres du
personnel
ce qui fait que l'équipe des droits
fondamentaux est de plus de 60 personnes
alors nous avons des procédures sur
les signalisation ou les notifications
liées aux violations de ou d'incident
grave concernant les droits fondamentaux
ce système était mis en place et
l'officier des droits fondamentaux à
accès à tout ce type de notification
mais à toute information qui peuvent
être pertinentes pour que l'équipe des
droits fondamentaux puisse accomplir ses
tâches
pour ce qui est la procédure de mise en
œuvre de l'article 46
et bien c'est la procédure pour laquelle
le directeur exécutif peut décider de
suspendre le financement ou suspendre
une partie où toutes les opérations au
sein des États membres
enfin
la stratégie en matière de droit
fondamentaux
a été adopté notamment le plan de mise
en oeuvre et les dispositifs au sujet de
l'officier des droits fondamentaux
qui établit des rapports d'avancement
concernant la mise en œuvre de la
stratégie
il aurait faire au conseil de direction
et on réfère au Conseil au Parlement
européen
en juin cette année si je me trompe pas
le concept de direction a décidé
d'obliger le directeur exécutif
de répondre aux recommandations de
l'officier de droit fondamentaux et des
recommandations du forum consultatif qui
se compose de représentants
d'organisations internationales
d'institutions dont des institutions de
l'Union européenne
l'agence de droit fondamentaux et des
représentants de la société civile
l'objectif de ce forum consultatif et
d'apporter des conseils à l'agence
concernant la conformité vis-à-vis des
droits fondamentaux
ensuite
nous avons
amélioré la transparence de nos
opérations
comment nous faisons liaison avec le
Parlement européen
nous avons répondu aux demandes d'accès
aux informations
et nous sommes appuyés sur la
recommandation du Médiateur européen et
enfin j'ai conscience que j'ai parlé
longtemps merci de votre patience
un certain nombre d'activités ont été
mises en oeuvre pour
améliorer le bien-être du personnel de
l'agence et améliorer la culture
managériale
et
je dirais d'abord que l'équipe de
direction de l'agence a consulté
commission du personnel le comité du
personnel
avec par ailleurs des experts détachés
pour cartographier les activités que
nous pouvons
conduire au côté du personnel de
l'agence
pour améliorer l'environnement de
travail et
le personnel prend pas pleinement à la
structure de prise de décision
sur la stratégie concernait les
ressources humaines
elle est en phase d'approbation elle
couvre 4 domaines la santé la sécurité
du personnel
qu'il s'agisse du signe au siège ou de
cette sécurité dans les théâtres
d'opération ensuite la diversité et
l'inclusion
il est ici question de l'égalité des
gens de l'équilibre géographique de
l'agence
et
la représentation des minorités
ensuite la culture de l'agence une
culture d'inclusivité
ne tolérance zéro concernant le
harcèlement
et
une culture
qui veut autonomiser la chaîne de prise
de décision et le personnel de lagence
et enfin il a encore c'est très
important
un dialogue social réussi c'est le
quatrième pilier un dialogue avec la
direction avec le personnel
et je dois dire cet égard que des
investissements considérables ont été
faits dans le domaine de la
communication la communication externe
avec les parties prenantes qu'il
s'agisse de la société civile ou
d'autres pas le braid qu'un autre
communication qu'il s'agisse du
Parlement et de la Commission européenne
et maintenant
c'est un vrai plaisir de pouvoir me
tenir à vos côtés une communication avec
les parlements nationaux
pour ce qui est des communications
internes
nous voulons pouvoir entendre le
personnel expliquer au personnel les
changements expliquez
quelle décision sont prises par la
direction et pourquoi et
vraiment pouvoir exploiter et
recueillir les données les informations
les connaissances du personnel
et en tirer profit je vais m'arrêter là
peut-être quelques mots au sujet de des
prochaines étapes
et des pistes d'amélioration des pistes
de développement
et je tiens à
à dire que nous
avons noté les conclusions de plusieurs
recommandations
qu'elles viennent de commissaire aux
comptes ou quasiment d'audition par Le
Mans
de rapport de l'OLAF mais je dois dire
que
l'agence a apporté une valeur ajoutée au
concept de direction l'agence a été
couronné de réussite dans son soutien
aux États membres
accomplissage y compris en des temps
difficiles
néanmoins il faut comprendre que
l'agence seul
n'est qu'une composante
dans la chaîne de valeur ajoutée pour ce
qui est la gestion d'abord de la
migration mais également de la sécurité
ce sont deux volets qui sont étroitement
liés
tous les sujets traités
il ne faut pas négliger cette ce volet
sécurité il est donc essentiel
de faire en sorte d'imbriquer l'agence
dans la réponse globale de l'Union
européenne des États membres de l'Union
européenne
au défi international migratoire et au
défi international sécuritaire
ce n'est qu'à ce moment-là que nous
aurons
le potentiel d'apporter une réponse
collective et de pouvoir faire en sorte
que notre travail porte ses fruits
beaucoup de ces éléments ne relèvent pas
de la compétence de l'agence Frontex
humanitaire au pays d'origine
le
les décisions politiques
et l'action publique il faut se
concentrer sur la manière dont la
gestion intégrée des frontières
qu'elle approche nous avons vis-à-vis de
cette gestion intégrée des frontières
comment on s'organise les gardes côté
garde frontières et
l'agence seul ne pourra pas atteindre
les objectifs fixés par la politique
européenne
l'agence doit travailler aux côtés des
États membres enfin
il nous faut nous pencher sur la manière
de prévenir de futurs menaces aux
frontières européennes avant que ces
menaces ne frappent lorsque ce menace
frappait souvent trop tard et
nous sommes alors face à une situation
qui est la situation actuelle
les frontières en Bulgarie par exemple
ou le niveau de violence est
considérable et c'est un défi qu'il nous
faut maintenant relever
la modernisation des frontières avec un
système d'entrée et de sortie et
les tiasses le système d'information et
d'autorisation sur les
déplacements
sont des composantes importantes
et cette modernisation
permet
d'empêcher que des menaces externes un
interfèrent avec
notre système donc il nous faut
moderniser ce système Ethias enfin
pour ce qui est
du continuum migratoire les retours ont
un rôle essentiel
pour gérer
les flux migratoires
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas le droit de
rester doivent retourner
un taux de retour si je ne me trompe pas
le taux ne dépasse pas 30%
ce qui signifie que 70% des migrants qui
n'ont pas le droit de rester au sein de
lieu ne sont pas retournés dans leur
pays et c'est là que fontex doit mieux
coopérer avec l'Union européenne et ses
États membres
il faut conclure les accords de
réadmission avec les pays d'origine pas
il n'y a pas d'état membre qui puisse
résoudre le problème seul
l'agence ne peut pas résoudre le
problème seul mais ensemble nous avons
bien plus de chances je vais m'arrêter
ici merci de votre patience
merci beaucoup madame et je propose sans
plus attendre et sans faire de
commentaires votre propos on y viendra
de commencer les questions de nos
collègues parce que la liste va
probablement s'étoffer je propose de
passer la parole à Didier Marie
merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Directrice le refus de
décharge budgétaires pour Frontex
intervenu
mi-octobre au Parlement européen et le
rapport de l'OLAF
indique que vous avez une lourde tâche à
accomplir pour
redonner crédit à l'agence et
rassurer
l'ensemble des États membres des
parlementaires
cela pose une question de principe une
question centrale qui est celle des
marges de manœuvre de votre agence à
l'égard des États membres donc vous êtes
aujourd'hui
dépendant dans la mise en œuvre de vos
actions et de votre capacité à
dire les choses lorsque un des États
membres ne respecte pas les droits
fondamentaux des migrants j'en viendrai
à une situation particulière
celle de la Grèce
qui a été accusé de refouler massivement
des migrants en provenance de Turquie
Frontex a été
accusé à minima de complaisance voir de
complicité
je voudrais savoir
quels sont aujourd'hui les dispositions
que votre agence a pu prendre pour
permettre que cette situation
soit
évacué et d'autre part vous demander
quels sont les relations que vous avez
aujourd'hui avec les autorités turques
pour permettre un apaisement dans la
relation entre la Turquie et la Grèce et
permettre
d'éviter
les situations que nous connaissons et
en particulier les naufrages et les
décès en mer Égée
également monsieur tanimamet
de la Commission de loi du Sénat
merci
monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice merci pour
vos éclairages j'aurai deux séries de
questions la première concerne la
Moldavie à mars dernier le conseil à
valider un accord de partenat de
partenariat entre Frontex et la Moldavie
pour soutenir ces dernières dans la
gestion de ses frontières dans le
contexte de la guerre en Ukraine vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure quel premier
bilan tirez-vous de ce partenariat
combien d'argent Frontex sont-ils
déployés et plus largement qu'il est le
bilan des partenariats de Frontex avec
les pays tiers ma deuxième série de
questions est relative aux régions
ultra périphériques de l'Union
européenne dont certaines sont
à l'exemple de du continent européen
sont soumises à une forte pression
migratoire notamment Mayotte la Guyane
et Saint-Martin mais mais pas que
localement des voies s'élèvent pour dire
que afin de garder les frontières
extérieures de l'Europe les rues font
partie intégrant de l'Europe
l'agence Frontex devrait intervenir
également dans ces rues
comme cela se passe par exemple au
Canaries ou au Madère il me semble le
cas échéant Madame la Directrice
qu'elles assuraient les conditions et
notamment juridiques et
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
perspective et opportune
merci
on en prend une encore là pour la Série
3 Claude Kern vice-président de la
Commission des affaires
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice merci pour votre
présentation ce matin vous avez
également parlé d'une autre mission clé
de l'agence à savoir la sécurité et à
travers ça la lutte contre le crime
transfrontalier or en alu dans un
rapport de la Cour des comptes
européennes ce rapport a pointé la place
trop limitée de
cette activité dans les activités de
Frontex alors comment abordez-vous cet
aspect et comment comptez-vous y pallier
par quel moyen et qu'elle devient
on vous laisse peut-être répondre madame
et on reprendra une série de trois
questions après
merci beaucoup merci je vais essayer
d'être brève
pour ce qui est de la décharge
budgétaire
alors ce n'est pas un retard en fait
nous avons eu une décision de la part du
Parlement européen qui refuse de donner
des charges pour le budget donc il y a
une liste de recommandations
de choses que l'agence doit prendre en
compte et il y a donc les préoccupations
qui sont exprimées par le Parlement
européen et là se réfère également au
constatation de Lola dans son rapport et
demande
à l'agence qu'elle fournissent une
feuille de route quant à la façon dont
ces manquements ou c'est lacunes vont
être géré
alors
je dois dire que
conjointement avec le conseil
d'administration
l'agence
vise à retrouver la confiance et
également à s'attaquer et à répondre à
ses recommandations il y a déjà une
liste de recommandations provenant des
premières constatations y compris le
rapport spécial préparer par
la Cour des comptes concernant le crime
transfrontalier
mais aussi
nous incluons maintenant les
recommandations provenant du rapport de
décharge ces recommandations seront
associées à des actions qu'il faudra
entreprendre cette liste
sera ensuite présentée au conseil
d'administration
régulièrement et chaque réunion du
conseil d'administration fera état de
des progrès réalisés et il y a également
des rapports qui seront fait
régulièrement au Parlement européen
concernant les progrès réalisés alors je
suis consciente du fait que le conseil
d'administration est en lien avec le
Parlement européen et cette façon a
permis d'améliorer la communication
entre les deux
l'agence enfin j'ai reçu une demande de
la part du groupe de travail de contrôle
de Frontex
nous demandons de fournir conformément à
la loi mégament de façon proactive au
Parlement européen des informations afin
de s'assurer qu'il soit bien informé des
progrès réalisés pour
rectifier les problèmes existants
j'aimerais revenir
au fait que vous avez mentionné monsieur
Meurice
concernant le fait que la liste est
longue et elle couvre un grand nombre de
points nous en sommes conscients c'est
la raison pour laquelle la première
chose que nous avons fait a été de
cartographier ce qui manquait en
conformité en transparence et en
conformité avec les règles financières
en conformité avec le droit
international etc donc nous avons
cartographié l'ensemble des actions qui
devaient être prises l'ensemble de
l'agence
à cette tâche parce que nous sommes
conscients du fait que
nous sommes sur le chemin nécessaire
pour retrouver la confiance et c'est
facile de perdre la confiance mais ça
prend plus de temps de regagner la
confiance des différents acteurs donc
une seule action ne sera pas suffisante
il faut vraiment agir de façon durable
au niveau de la chanson
maintenant pour ce qui est de la
capacité à s'exprimer à
interpeller si un État membre n'est pas
en conformité avec les droits
fondamentaux
alors j'espérais pouvoir aborder cette
question avant mais j'aimerais
vous présenter quelques aspects
spécifiques
de
des États membres alors tout d'abord
l'agence en tant que telle n'a pas de
pouvoir d'enquête sur les États membres
et d'ailleurs ça ne devrait pas être le
cas le législateur a eu tout à fait
raison en ne donnant pas en une
conférent pas c'est pouvoir d'enquête à
l'agence il y a des autorités nationales
des autorités internationales y compris
des autorités judiciaires qui
jouent ce rôle
le fichier pour les droits fondamentaux
qui est une fonction indépendante et
le seul la seule entité de l'agence si
vous voulez qui a le droit de mener une
enquête sur des violations des droits
fondamentaux ou violation potentielles
des droits fondamentaux
en opération conjointe avec les États
membres
pour ce qui est de la graisse plus
précisément suite au rapport de l'OLAF
mais également les avis émis par
l'officier aux droits fondamentaux
nous avons avec l'officier au droit
fondamentaux des avril mai juin juillet
tâcher de
répondre à ces préoccupations et là à
nouveau
s'il y a de façon systématique et
j'insiste sur les termes s'il y a des
violations systématiques des droits
fondamentaux par les États membres les
rectifier rectifier la situation et
quelque chose qui prend du temps et
c'est pourquoi nous demandons aux
autorités et les nées de présenter un
plan de mise en oeuvre quelque chose de
structurel qui pourra vraiment remédier
assez manquements en matière de respect
des droits fondamentaux montrer qu'il y
a un cadre indépendant qui peut
répondre à ces problèmes et il remédier
donc voilà de quelle façon nous
travaillons et moi à titre personnel je
travaille avec les États membres il
s'agit d'un dialogue parce que lorsque
il y a des violations des droits
fondamentaux lorsqu'elles sont avérées
il est de notre intérêt commun de les
résoudre collectivement
pour ce qui est de la Moldavie
l'accord
de statut c'est
deux permettre à la agence de déployer
son personnel sans contingent permanent
avec des pouvoirs exécutifs qu'est-ce
que j'entends par là et bien c'est que
nous pouvons être à la frontière et
participer au contrôle des frontières
nous portons des uniformes nous portons
des armes et nous pouvons agir nous
pouvons
travailler aux côtés
des
personnels
des pays hautes et dans le cas présent
en Moldavie au pic
de
la grève nous avons eu
18 membres du personnel déployés dans
les aéroports au point de contrôle des
hauts
de passage des frontières pardon vers la
République de moldovie à l'heure
actuelle nous avons 73 membres du
personnel qui sont déployés
les valuation par les moldavres et j'ai
la possibilité de m'entretenir avec le
chef du service de garde de frontière de
Moldavie il y a peu et ce travail est
vraiment apprécié parce que il manque
considérablement de personnel dans la
région il manque également d'équipements
techniques dans la région et par
ailleurs
manque de connaissances concernant les
méthodes modernes de gestion des
frontières
là vous savez peut-être que la Moldavie
a présenté une demande de candidature
pour devenir État membre de l'Union
européenne ça va
demander un certain temps mais à nouveau
nous continuons à appuyer les autorités
moldave dans ce cheminement afin de
pouvoir être en conformité avec les
normes et standards européens en matière
de gestion des frontières
maintenant parlons de la coopération
avec les pays tiers de manière générale
à nouveau j'aimerais répéter ce que j'ai
déjà dit par le passé il est
indispensable de travailler avec les
États voisins et même au-delà
tout d'abord c'est important pour
pouvoir comprendre la situation la
pression migratoire à laquelle ces pays
sont confrontés afin de pouvoir
travailler également avec les autorités
à l'heure actuelle la plupart du travail
que nous réalisons avec des pays en
dehors de l'Union Européenne et réaliser
dans le cadre d'accord de travail et il
y a une différence entre ces accords ces
arrangements de travail et des accords
de statut en fait parce que
c'est walking Rajman c'est bien ces
accords de travail ce sont des formes
allégées d'accord entre Frontex et les
états tandis que les accords de statut
sont négociés par la Commission
européenne
et seulement
seul ces accords de statut donnent à
l'agence le droit de déployer du
personnel avec des pouvoirs exécutifs
dans le cadre des boire King orange donc
les accords de travail il s'agit de
travail
sur la situation c'est plus un statut
d'observateur
que ce soit au niveau de l'agence dans
les États tiers
et dans la façon dont les uns et les
autres opère donc il est important de
s'impliquer dans ses efforts et
le nombre de ces accords de travail
à l'heure actuelle
nous avons bien avancé avec le Sénégal
la Mauritanie et il y a deux semaines
j'ai une réunion très fructueuse avec le
Maroc nous nous sommes mis d'accord sur
la formalisation de notre bonne
collaboration opérationnelle par la
signature d'un accord de travail et
potentiellement en tout cas je l'espère
à l'avenir un accord de statut
le crime transfrontière maintenant alors
merci beaucoup d'avoir posé cette
question ce qui me ramène à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
nous devons parler de la gestion des
frontières et la gestion des frontières
ça inclut la gestion des migrations la
criminalité transfrontalière
aux frontières c'est la dernière fois
que l'on peut arrêter la criminalité que
on peut l'empêcher d'entrer dans l'Union
européenne donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important il faut que la
criminalité transfrontalière que le
terrorisme transfrontalié soit quelque
chose que l'on vise avec beaucoup
d'efforts au niveau des frontières et
moi je salue le rapport de la Cour des
comptes je salue le renforcement de
l'aspect transfrontalier dans le
règlement 2019 et je dois dire quand le
règlement a été adopté en 2016 ce
n'était ça ne figurerait pas c'était
mentionné mais il manquait quelque chose
en fait il y avait une sorte de vide
juridique l'aspect législatif n'était
pas suffisant et l'agence n'avait pas la
possibilité d'échanger des données
personnelles concernant la criminalité
transfrontalière désormais c'est le cas
nous pouvons
fournir des données personnelles au
sujet des suspects de criminalité
transfrontalière ou de personnes qui
sont arrêtées
et qui
réalise des criminelles à la frontière
donc nous pouvons agir avec les États
membres et européens donc il est
indispensable que Frontex
soit intégré dans le cycle de sûreté
total que nos collaborions avec Europole
ce qui est le cas car j'aimerais vous
rappeler que seuls les États membres ont
le droit de mener des enquêtes ce n'est
pas quelque chose que frontext a le
droit de fermer au moyen des contrôles
aux frontières au moyen des activités de
surveillance aux frontières Frontex peut
fournir un appui aux Etats membres afin
de détecter ces activités criminelles
aux frontières il y a les activités de
débriefing qui permettent de fournir des
renseignements sur les choses les plus
importantes à savoir les activités
criminelles qui organisent le passage
illégal de migrants
le passage
le trafic d'armes également la traite
d'êtres humains la traite de mineur donc
c'est pourquoi nous devons travailler
très secrètement avec les États membres
les institutions de l'Union européenne
Europole
Frontex également bien entendu et
aussi euro juste donc voilà je vais
m'arrêter là merci
merci Madame la parole monsieur André
Richard
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice je vais vous poser trois
questions
la première a lieu pardon la première
concerne les moyens dont vous disposez
pour faire face à votre mission je
m'explique
vous avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure
que nous assistons à l'heure actuelle à
une augmentation importante du nombre de
de
migrants illégaux nous en rendons compte
bien sûr dans les différents pays de
l'Union européenne
comme en France en particulier
l'augmentation de migrants est un du
nombre du migrants est un fait et
clairement se pose la question pour nous
de la surveillance des frontières
extérieures de cette union européenne
est-ce que vous avez des moyens
bien sûr Frontex n'est pas vous le
disiez insister vous insistez tout à
l'heure à cet égard
pas le seul le seul outil les pays
concernés naturellement par ses
frontières extérieures sont sont
concernés en premier chef mais est-ce
que vous Frontex a les moyens d'assurer
véritablement une bonne surveillance de
ces frontières extérieures on appuie aux
États c'était ma première question ma
deuxième question a lieu au modalités de
fonctionnement de Frontex vous le savez
comme moi à l'heure actuelle le pack
asile migration proposé par la
Commission
on est toujours pas adopté un certain
nombre d'États membres ils sont nombreux
et mettre de vivre réserves à cet égard
même si la crise ukrainienne a un peu
amélioré la situation avec les pays
d'Isola mais
à l'heure actuelle on est loin d'une
approbation globale de ce package
d'immigration seul deux étapes semblent
à peu près
recueillir le screening et puis la
volonté de de d'améliorer Eurodac
notamment mais
comment pouvez-vous Frontex vous
l'agence peut-elle fonctionner dans des
conditions
de ce type ou à la limite chaque pays
chaque pays fait ce qu'il entend faire
chaque pays frontalier dans ses
frontières extérieures fait ce qu'il
veut on n'a pas d' accord encore même
sur le screening on n'a pas d'accord
entre les différents pays et si la Corée
donnée il n'est pas réalisé comme il le
devrait enfin avec toutes les dérives
que l'on voit ensuite dès lors qu'une
personne est rentrée dans une frontière
extérieure naturellement elle se promène
comme elle le veut encore que vous le
savez un certain nombre de pays ont
maintenu les frontières intérieures
et heureusement d'ailleurs enfin
troisième question
très direct à la suite des critiques qui
ont été portées sur le fonctionnement de
Frontex on a bien noté tous votre
préoccupation de
[Musique]
le temps de contraintes pour votre
fonctionnement qui se font au détriment
de l'efficience et de l'efficacité et
clairement des attentes des populations
européennes à des gars d'une bonne
gestion une bonne surveillance des
frontières extérieures jour merci merci
Monsieur encore deux questions madame
Patricia Schillinger Monsieur Pierre
Laurent
si Madame la Directrice dans la comptine
d'unité de la première question de André
reichhardt l'agence s'affiche un retard
dans la constitution du Corps européen
de garde de frontières et de gare de
côtes qui prévoit le recrutement de
10000 gare de frontières et gare de
côtes ce retard est d'autant plus criant
que la présidente de la Commission
européenne souhaite que ce recrutement
s'achève en 2024 soit 3 ans plus tôt que
l'échéance votait par le Parlement
européen où en est-on aujourd'hui
quels sont les défis principaux de
recrutement comment faire face aux
problèmes d'attractivité de l'agence en
termes de conditions de travail
notamment de rémunération et au manque
de représentativité des nationalités
merci
merci madame Monsieur Pierre Laurent
oui merci quelques questions brèves
Madame la Directrice la première c'est
quel bilan tirez-vous de la gestion du
flot de réfugiés
ukrainien et notamment de l'utilisation
du statut de protection temporaire
comment est-ce que vous appréciez la
situation est-ce que le flot de réfugiés
continue à quel rythme comment vous
voilà quelles leçons tirez-vous de la
gestion de cette crise
sur la manière d'envisager
l'accueil
en Europe deuxièmement vous avez
deuxième question vous avez
fait allusion à plusieurs reprises
à propos de la montée de la violence
dans les corridors de migration des
Balkans
du rôle des du trafic d'armes dans cette
dans cette région
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus est-ce que c'est un trafic
d'armes qui vient d'où qui vient de
l'Ukraine qui vient de
plus loin
quel est l'ampleur de ce phénomène
est-ce que vous pouvez être plus précis
sur ce point troisième question vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de de
l'augmentation significative du nombre
de retour en donnant des chiffres sur
les retours forcés et les retours
volontaires
ma question est de savoir vers quel pays
ont eu lieu ces 20.000 retours puisque
si j'ai bien noté les chiffres il y a à
peu près 20 000 retours en 2021 vers
quel pays ont été ont été menés ce
retour soit volontaire soit forcé et
enfin ma dernière question
concerne la situation Méditerranée la
situation humanitaire en Méditerranée
qui reste
très dramatique
il y a eu un incident
diplomatique récent autour de l'accueil
d'un bateau humanitaire discussion trop
l'Italie et la France où on est on de
cette question de l'accès des bateaux
humanitaires
au port aux Européens merci
merci je propose comme on a eu deux
inscrits en plus de leur donner la
parole tout de suite Jean-Michel
Houlgate et Jacques Pernic oui mais
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la Directrice parmi les frontières
extérieures de l'Union européenne il
existe une frontière toute particulière
c'est la mère de la Manche frontière
particulière parce que il ne s'agit pas
à cette fois-ci d'empêcher les migrants
d'entrée mais plutôt de les empêcher de
sortir et à ce titre les autorités
britanniques et françaises ont recensé
en 2021
52000 52000 traversées soit 5 fois plus
qu'en 2020 alors c'est vrai que que le
Royaume-Uni et l'Irlande aussi sont
extrêmement attractifs et constituent
donc un point de
de d'attractivité donc pour pour les
migrants c'est aussi une frontière
particulière puisque elle est gérée par
des accords bilatéraux les accords du
Touquet mais néanmoins donc Frontex
intervient et il y a un peu plus d'un an
maintenant donc un avion armé parler
danois d'ailleurs pour pour Frontex
opère une surveillance dans la mer de la
Manche donc je voulais savoir un peu
quel était votre analyse de la situation
de la mère de la Manche et et qu'elle
pourrait être d'une certaine façon
est-ce qu'il faut dénoncer les accords
du Touquet quel est quel est votre
vision des choses
oui merci monsieur le Président oui
j'aurais pas tout à fait la même
appréciation ça n'étonnera pas que que
mon collègue André Richard je pense pas
que le la question du souci des droits
du respect des droits fondamentaux ne
pose que des que des contraintes de la
bureaucratie et et
entrave le bon fonctionnement et la
bonne réalisation des objectifs de
Frontex
dans dans toute la série de dispositifs
que vous avez mis en place
donc suite suite à la crise suite à
évidemment la démission du de votre
prédécesseur peut pas tout résoudre il y
a toute une série de dispositifs de de
repérage de notification des manquements
au droit fondamentaux donc on comprend
l'intérêt pour pour les prévenir pour
les éviter qu'est-ce qu'il en est
d'éventuelles sanctions réparation suite
à ces manquements et sinon deuxième
question vous avez évoqué l'accord
de statut de travail avec le Maroc qui
est en perspective on pense tous aux
drames de Melilla
comment on peut mener des opérations
conjointes coopérer avec des des pays
qui manifestement
ne respectent pas les droits
fondamentaux je pense aussi à la Libye
allez-y je vous en prie
merci infiniment pour vos questions je
tâcherai de répondre à autant de
questions que possible
du mieux que je peux si vous estimez que
je n'ai pas répondu à vos questions
je vous invite à me le faire savoir et
nous vous enverrons davantage de réponse
par écrit il se peut que je
j'oublie
de vous apporter tous les éléments
souhaité ou que il se peut que j'oublie
quelque chose alors je vais commencer
par les ressources les moyens financiers
alors le règlement prévoit
près de 10000 nom du personnel à l'heure
actuelle donc ce ne sont pas dix mille
membres du personnel de l'agence
parmi ces 10000 personnes il y a trois
catégories de personnels
le personnel permanent de fontex à
hauteur de 3000 personnes il y a ensuite
les détachements à long terme
personne ne voyait parler
c'est un membre 1500 personnes et les
autres ont du personnel
travaille dans le cadre de détachement
à court terme donc on parle de la
catégorie 3 du contingent permanent
avec un détachement de 1 à 4 mois pour
des activités opérationnelles alors
j'aimerais vous donner un aperçu
sur le nombre de personnes déployées à
l'heure actuelle
1843 officiers du contingent permanent
sont déployés et
605 sont membres du personnel de fantaxe
463 sont des détachement à long terme ce
sont des détachements de 2 ans et
815 membres de la catégorie 3 les
détachements à court terme
cette année
nous avons pu voir que
un besoin existe d'avoir cette
constellation avoir trois catégories
distinctes de membres du personnel
pourquoi
parce que la situation aux frontières
extérieures et changeante
elle a changé après la crise en Ukraine
et il n'y avait
nous avons prévu nos opérations l'année
précédente
fixer les ressources à louer et cette
crise n'était pas prévue
elle était inattendue et nous avons
compris qu'il fallait renforcer le
soutien apporté au pays en première
ligne aux frontières
ukrainiennes
nous nous sommes d'abord penchés sur des
redéploiements internes
ont été rendus possibles très rapidement
la première vague de déploiement s'est
faite en Roumanie
elle était effectuée
l'espace d'une semaine donc des membres
sur des théâtres opérationnels au sein
de l'UE
en Espagne en Italie en Grèce dans les
pays baltes et ailleurs
ont pu être redéployés
aux frontières ukrainiennes et en
Roumanie notamment en l'espace de 7
jours
les déploiement en Moldavie qui était
nouveau
ce sont faits en trois jours redéplamant
en trois jours néanmoins
cela n'est qu'une partie des
redéploiements
nécessaires puisque au début de la
guerre
nous déployons près de 600 membres du
personnel aux frontières ukrainiennes
et la plupart ne ces personnes étaient
envoyées par les États membres
dans le cadre de déploiement à court
terme
et c'est là toute la flexibilité du
système qui est bâti nous devons
garantir
que
en détente difficile on est contexte
difficile
nous ne retardons pas la réponse
opérationnelle lorsqu'elle est
nécessaire
il faut pouvoir faire preuve flexibilité
pour éviter
d'être vulnérable dans d'autres régions
donc pouvoir utiliser les ressources des
amendes dans le cas de ces déploiements
à court terme nous permet de pouvoir
apporter une réponse aux besoins qui
émergent de façon ponctuelle lorsque
l'agence finalise le recrutement
ne sont personnel donc à hauteur de 3000
membres
et lorsque nous sommes en pleine
capacité pour ce qui est des
détachements des États membres alors
on peut avoir plus de 3000 officiers
prêts à être déployés néanmoins
en cas de besoin
inattendu
d'abord nous déployons là où nous le
pouvons mais les autres
ou le reste de la réponse vient des
déploiements des amendes j'espère que je
suis claire dans mon explication
j'en viens au modalités de
fonctionnement de l'agence contexte
maintenant
dans le cadre politique actuel
et j'étais ravi de voir que
dans le programme du travail de la
commission pour l'année prochaine
l'accent est mis sur les le pacte
migratoire
et puisque comme je l'ai dit auparavant
l'agence frontale
ne peut pas être la seule à partir d'une
réponse au défi migratoires à moins que
nous n'ayons
une stratégie en matière d'action
publique avec des politiques publiques
fortes
qui s'appliquent dans toute l'Union
européenne dans les États membres de
l'Union européenne et qui s'appliquent
qu'aux frontières
au garde frontières et aux garde-côtes
alors
il sera très difficile de gérer les
frontières
et
Frontex aura du mal à porter un soutien
ou car de frontières
et c'est là que les décideurs politiques
vont devoir amplifier leurs efforts
et relever ce défi
il est clair que la crise en Ukraine a
donné un nouvel élan
et je ne peux qu'espérer
que les résultats seront fructueux pour
ce qui est des opérations de Frontex
dans un environnement tel que celui-ci
et bien nous fonctionnons comme avant
la gestion des frontières est une
compétence qui relève des États membres
nous apportons un soutien aux étangs aux
États membres du mieux que nous pouvons
en utilisant le cadre juridique existant
et
bien évidemment les droits fondamentaux
[Musique]
ne sont pas une question bureaucratique
les droits
fondamentaux ne s'appliquent pas qu'aux
personnel de l'agence c'est droit
fondamentaux doivent être garantis pour
tous les individus
et ce ne sont pas deux éléments en
parallèle
ni le personnel de l'agence Frontex ni
les personnels des États membres ne
surveillent le matin et décide voilà
aujourd'hui je vais appliquer une partie
de telle ou telle réglementation et pas
le reste non nous appliquons
toute la réglementation
nous respectons tout le droit en vigueur
en matière de gestion des frontières
le cadre des droits fondamentaux de
l'agence
est extraordinaire
je dois admettre que les opérations
conjoines
menées par Frontex à ce jour sont très
bien suivis il y a un mécanisme de suivi
des droits fondamentaux il y a le forme
consultatif qui se rend sur les théâtres
opérationnels qui apporte des
recommandations nous avons le conseil
d'administration le groupe de contrôle
parlementaire
des groupes de contrôle
pour assurer un suivi de nos opérations
et
en toute honnêteté le système actuel
avec des notifications sur les
violations des droits de l'homme des
droits fondamentaux
est un système qui fonctionne
le personnel de l'agence bien formé en
matière de droit fondamentaux le
personnel
est compétent
des rapports sont faits lorsqu'il y a
des violations des atteintes mais il
faut comprendre que quel que soit le
système en place il ne pourra pas être
complètement étanche
ce que nous avons mis en oeuvre c'est un
mécanisme pour tenir compte de
d'atteinte au droit fondamentaux
et
violation qu'elle soit par le
contingent permanent ou pas d'autres
parties prenantes et il y aura de telles
violations un moment ou un autre il faut
un système permettant de traiter c'est
atteintes
et nous voulons pouvoir apporter
davantage d'informations sur le cadre de
sanctions le cadre disciplinaire
et je vous apporterai ces informations
supplémentaires si vous le souhaitez
bien évidemment
je suis entièrement d'accord avec le
fait que l'agence contact doit porter
apporter un bon soutien aux États
membres
nous coopérons il faut parieur coopérer
avec les pays tiers les pays les pays
d'accueil pardon et
nous devons analyser l'efficacité des
opérations de Frontex sur les
territoires de ces pays haute du pays
d'accueil
l'année dernière nous avons mis en place
de nouveaux indicateurs clés de
performance qui présentent des résultats
satisfaisants
dans les pays qui reçoivent le soutien
de Frontex et
ce peut être surprenant mais
j'attends avec impatience de pouvoir
consulter les retours des États membres
parce que ça nous permettra
d'orienter nos activités opérationnelles
à l'avenir pour répondre aux besoins de
l'agence contexte Frontex est là à la
disposition des États membres ce n'est
pas l'inverse
j'en viens ensuite
à la composition du contingent permanent
et sur le retard
nous avons fait de notre mieux pour
répondre aux exigences en matière de
recrutement
conformément au règlement et à l'heure
actuelle nous avons
deux grandes vagues de contingents
permanent
en formation qui sera opérationnel de
l'année prochaine
à partir de janvier 2023
Frontex pourra déployer
1000 membres de
personnel et le reste restant du démon
du personnel sera proposé par les États
membres conformément disposition du
règlement
avec détachement à long terme et à plus
court terme
à juste titre vous avez abordé deux
points l'attractivité ne font pas que en
tant qu'employeur et la représentation
des nationalités
tout d'abord
il faut se rappeler ce qu'est le
contingent permanent il s'agit d'un
contingent déployé sur les théâtres
opérationnels pas d'états membres ou
d'organisations internationales ne peut
déployer de personnel avec pouvoir
exécutif
à plus de 200 emplacements simultanément
seulement l'agence peut le faire avec la
constellation que nous avons c'est
catégories de membres du personnel nous
le pouvons et il y a cette exigence de
redéployer du personnel d'une zone
opérationnelle à une autre
les conditions ou les raisons de
redéployer le personnel sont diverses un
travail difficile dans certains avions
plus que dans d'autres ensuite
le besoin de garantir qu'il y a un
roulement satisfaisant que
le personnel ne se retrouve pas en
bourbé en quelque sorte et il nous
faudra redéployer du personnel d'une
zone à une autre plusieurs fois par an
j'ai vu des officiers du contingent
permanent redéployez quatre fois
en l'espace d'un an et demi et ce n'est
pas une bonne vie
il n'y a pas de garantie qu'une personne
sera déployée dans une zone
opérationnelle pendant 5 ans ça serait
formidable pour la vie de famille alors
ça en soi c'est un défi c'est un défi
pour le contingent permanent et
particulièrement pour le personnel de
l'agence qui est recruté pour 5 ans plus
5 ans c'est leur travail il n'y aura pas
de stabilité
et cela en fait un impact sur
l'attractivité même si les gens sont
prêts à relever le défi les choses
peuvent changer une fois que les gens se
marient ont des enfants il y a la
question de la scolarisation des enfants
et nous essayons de voir quels sont les
possibilités pour fournir la
scolarisation dans les théâtres
d'opérations entre autres deuxième point
qui concerne l'attractivité c'est le
coefficient de correction je dois le
dire
de Varsovie et j'aimerais vous expliquer
en quoi cela consiste
c'est un coefficient qui est appliqué au
salaire standard des agents de l'Union
européenne
afin de s'assurer
qu'il y ait
des situations égales pour tout le monde
au sein de l'Union européenne
alors c'est vrai que le coût de la vie
varie au sein de l'Union européenne mais
le coefficient
de Varsovie ne reflète pas la réalité du
coup de la vie ça c'est en fait
et c'est l'impact également de la guerre
parce que lorsque la guerre a été
déclenchée
la Pologne
a totalement accueilli les réfugiés et à
donner la possibilité aux gens d'y
rester et les gens veulent à rester là
parce qu'ils veulent ensuite retourner
chez eux c'est pourquoi il ne souhaite
pas véritablement changer d'état membres
c'est la même chose pour la Moldavie
pour la Roumanie pour les États baltes
pour la Pologne
et pour la Slovaquie voilà je
en fait les gens ils veulent rentrer
chez eux c'est la raison pour laquelle
il reste là et le prix des loyers ont
simplement explosé rien qu'en quelques
mois
donc le coefficient de correction
c'est quelque chose qui a aussi des
répercussions sur l'attractivité et il y
a aussi
l'équilibre géographique dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure dans votre question
ce sont les raisons pour lesquelles
c'est plus difficile de recruter des
gens et de recruter des gens en
provenance de l'ensemble des pays de
l'Union européenne à nouveau
nous sommes conscients du fait nous le
signalons au Parlement à la Commission
européenne aux États membres dès que
c'est possible mais également en interne
nous
nous avons employé deux officiers à la
diversité afin de s'assurer également
que cette question de la diversité soit
abordée donc les enseignements tirés de
la crise migratoire en provenance du
crâne
je dois dire que le plus grand
enseignement était que nous en tant
qu'organisation nous avons fait preuve
d'une énorme flexibilité et d'une grande
rapidité donc nous avons prouvé nous
nous sommes prouvés à nous-mêmes en
premier lieu mais également au parti
prenante que nous sommes capables de se
déployer de se redéployer en très peu de
temps lorsque c'est véritablement
nécessaire
nous avons également appris que en tant
qu'organisation nous avions
pu appuyer les États membres pour les
aider à prendre en charge les flux
énormes aux frontières
alors un petit peu plus quelques mots au
sujet des violences
la première fois que nous avons détecté
des violences en 2020
c'était à Évreux les fusillades à évrose
et de façon sporadique on a constaté des
tirs tous les ans il y a eu des rapports
d'incidents l'an dernier des rapports
d'incidents graves signalant des tirs à
Evros mais pas uniquement il y a aussi
la violence qui existe entre les
différents groupes de migrants
donc il faut établir une distinction
entre ce type de violence et la violence
à l'encontre des gardes frontières là on
gris a signalé
lors de réunion du conseil
d'administration à la montrer des vidéos
montrant à combien la violence avait
augmenté à la frontière avec la Serbie
et si nécessaire je suis tout à fait
prête à présenter plus de détails au
Sénat mais plus récemment l'indique
comme je vous le disais un garde
frontière a été tué en Bulgarie et c'est
le premier décès à la frontière d'un
garde frontière du à cette violence il a
été visé dans la tête
et ce qui montre bien que ce n'était pas
du tout un tiers accidentel
l'objectif était de tuer
nous augmentons
les équipements de protection pour notre
personnel et dans les opérations nous
donnons également cet équipement aux
personnel des États membres qui ne sont
peut-être pas équipés ou qui ont des
qualités d'équipements inférieurs aux
autres
pour ce qui est des retours
si je ne me trompe pas mais alors s'il
vous plaît
prenez ces chiffres quand même avec une
certaine pincée de sel mais je me
rappelle pas exactement combien de
personnes
ont fait l'objet d'un retour mais je
crois que c'est autour de 70 mais je
serai heureuse de répondre à des
questions et d'ajouter la liste des pays
mais en tout cas c'était assez étendu
donc Pakistan l'Inde
des retours volontaires vers l'Irak
notamment aussi
suite à la crise en Biélorussie avec
l'instrumentalisation des retours
volontaires
de ressortissants de pays tiers qui
voulait échapper à la guerre en Ukraine
et également d'un grand nombre d'autres
pays mais je pourrais vous fournir la
liste détaillée
par la suite afin que vous ayez des
renseignements précis
pour
répondre à la question
portant sur la crise humanitaire
entre l'Italie
en fait cela relève de la prérogative
des États membres c'est aux États
membres de décider de quelle façon il
gère leur frontières extérieur et
j'aimerais
vous rappelez ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure à savoir que
la gouvernance
des
gardes frontières et des garde-côtes
alors moi le forum de Schengen pour moi
c'est un des outils de cette gouvernance
et je pense que ce genre de question
devrait être posée
par le biais du mécanisme de gouvernance
même chose
pour la situation dans la Manche vous
avez tout à fait raison lorsque vous
dites qu'il y a une augmentation
significative et nous appuyons les
autorités de gestion des frontières
françaises
au moyen de surveillance aérienne
dans le cadre d'une opération conjointe
avec
nous continuerons à le faire
pendant l'année qui arrive
et si les autorités françaises demandent
une augmentation de l'empreinte
opérationnelle dans le cadre de cette
opération conjointe côte opale pardon
par opencluse mais
c'est une des
zones où on a effectivement la plus
grande augmentation de la pression
migratoire maintenant pour ce qui est
des droits fondamentaux
et des rapports
le rapport
le signalement d'incident ou d'incident
grave
à deux pans donc tout d'abord cela est
signalé par le personnel de Frontex et
c'est aussi signalé par les États
membres donc les États membres ajoute
tous les incidents de gestion aux
frontières
dans le système Jorat qui est utilisé
comme base
d'évaluation des risques
aux frontières
avec ces deux types de rapport
et de signalement les incidents sérieux
sont ainsi
identifiés signaler il y a des rapports
d'incident qui sont préparés et ils sont
immédiatement envoyés à l'officier
responsable des droits fondamentaux et
si l'on soupçonne une violation des
droits fondamentaux dans ce cas c'est
l'officier qui est chargé de ce dossier
incident grave pour ce qui est de la
coopération avec des pays tiers
j'aimerais vous dire que
aucun accord de statut
n'est conclu
sans que il y ait une évaluation de la
situation dans les tiers en matière de
droit fondamentaux j'espère que cela
vous rassure quant au niveau de
coopération avec les pays tiers et je
vais m'arrêter là merci
merci Madame la Directrice voilà bon
voilà vous avez quand même bien balayé
toutes les questions qui vous ont été
posées mais certaines restent sans
réponse je pense aux rues notamment etc
donc je crois que les services des deux
commissions peut-être s'organiseront
pour pour vous envoyer un courrier
complémentaire pour pouvoir répondre
plus précisément à ces questions en tout
cas je vous remercie je sais aussi que
les services de nos deux commissions se
sont organisés pour envoyer un
questionnaire important
concernant la révision du du règlement
Frontex donc là aussi avec un délai de
réponse courant décembre et merci merci
d'y répondre ça nous permettra à la fois
des éclairages mais aussi des deux
nouvelles perspectives d'audition si
nous nous voulions des informations
complémentaires en tout cas au nom de
tous les collègues des deux commissions
mais aussi du président buffet qui est
remplacé temporairement par par le
président Tani que je souhaitais vous
remercier de de d'avoir libéré une heure
et demie à notre égard et pour nous
informer de la situation de Frontex qui
croyait le et vous l'avez exposé en
situant certaines régions françaises est
une préoccupation du quotidien notamment
pour le
sénateur dont je représente le
département du Pas-de-Calais que je suis
et qui est confronté sur la Côte d'Opale
à la situation très très dégradée et qui
se dégrade j'ai vu les services de
gendarmerie récemment avec un doublement
on peut déjà le dire
alors que l'année n'est pas terminée un
doublement des tentatives de traverser
par rapport à l'année dernière voilà
merci Madame la directrice et bonne
journée
merci beaucoup merci et j'aimerais une
nouvelle fois vous remercier de m'avoir
donné la possibilité de m'exprimer
aujourd'hui de façon tout à fait ouverte
et transparente
et bien entendu je serais ravie de
prendre la parole nouvelle fois de
répondre à vos questions je vous ai
promis la transparence de l'ouverture et
bien entendu même si les questions sont
douloureuses nous y répondrons et
j'aimerais vraiment vous remercier pour
le soutien
que vous avez exprimé à plusieurs
reprises
à l'agence et vous avez également
signaler le travail et le
professionnalisme du personnel je leur
ferai part de votre soutien de vos
remerciements sans plus attendre et ça
sera vraiment très important à leurs
yeux merci beaucoup